hey caitlin hey evan you know it's a
weird thing to think about
what how this might be one of the very
last podcasts we ever do
at this house that would be weird
it would be very weird how many times
can i do that
the very last podcast joke i don't know
you've done it within like a few
different scenarios a few different
scenarios
but i think before we get into the main
topic of today which are
lessons we've learned from this very
first house that we have lived in
um and what we might have done
differently what's good and bad what are
the things we love
and aren't crazy about in the in this
house let's first do
a little what's new segment
news news news news news news
news okay what's news with you what's
news with me
i didn't prepare well what about our our
uh
our new uh twitch account okay yeah
brand new twitch account breaking news
breaking news we um did a little april
fool's joke
and we are you gonna keep the news
background okay
we did a little april fool's joke and we
decided to make the supervisor her own
twitch channel
because everybody always wants a catio
cam and so we just decided
let's have a catio it was a great april
fool's joke
it was a great april fool's joke because
it also delivered something real
it ended up being so awesome that we're
just doing it now
semi-regularly we've done a couple catio
streams
and a stream where she was just like in
her bed in the living room she has had a
much
more successful start of her twitch
career than we did
like she's gonna hit like affiliate and
partner in no time
yeah she can do it too affiliate in a
few days than
we were obviously by this point what the
heck what the heck
in other news news news um i'm not sure
if you guys have noticed in my videos
but i've
kind of been walking around kind of like
in poor shape because i threw my back
out during
our um mood ring keyboard painting
all of the painting we did for this i
threw my back out and i'm still
recovering
like weeks later and that concludes news
news news back back to you podcast
well yeah
yeah i i do feel bad about your back i
feel like it's taking longer than normal
it's taking oh well i think that the
main problem is is it starts feeling
better and then i start pushing myself
and
doing more and getting back to my
regular life probably before i should
which just regresses it so i'm going to
try to be responsible
yeah but it is hard because like we have
a whole extra thing on our plate which
is
house hunting and getting this house
ready for
moving and like all all these very
exciting things and the house hunting
trips in the car
long hours probably aren't good for the
back either yeah
yeah but we thought um because we
already did a podcast
about um house hunting and some of what
we're looking for and our thoughts and
the challenges
we thought it would also be fun to do a
little podcast about our current house
because when we asked patreon
what type of house moving related
content they wanted
we had a ton of a ton of input but um
there was a theme of questions
about our current house so we thought
like before we get too far ahead of
ourselves
yeah let's uh let's talk about that well
and also i might do a little aside
because you know i think that we we link
our patreon with our main channel a lot
but patreon is probably one of the best
places to support us generally
yeah so if you want to support the
podcast the patreon
is the best place for that too
patreon.com evan and katelyn
i thought i'd just do like the the
smallest of plugs there because because
um i i love patreon um so i think we can
start with uh what we learned from this
very first house that we are in
right now yeah there's so much there's
so much here's an overall thing i will
say
i am so glad that
we have been i mean we've been very very
lucky that we've been able
to be in a house
before this next house like as a as
opposed to an apartment we
we moved from our apartment to this
house because it was actually
i mean one reason was because of your
job and we needed to move anyway but
also it was
cheaper it was than our apartment now we
had to be able to
save enough money to afford the down
payment but after the down payment it
was cheaper than our apartment
yeah and so even though we were pretty
young
when we bought the house i guess
compared to the average
people these days um i'm so glad that we
just kind of like made that jump even
though it was kind of scary because i
feel like
having a starter house
has taught us a lot about what to look
for
in our new house now that we are older
and we have more specific
needs you know and and we've like you
know we've
not only saved money from uh
you know paying you know the monthly
rate of living in the apartment that
we're living at versus the monthly rate
of living here
we were also building equity in the
house and that led us
you know it was it was a good financial
decision all the way around yeah but
there's also just so much that we
learned about being
homeowners and like a lot of these
lessons we actually
kind of learned and experimented with
before we even started the channel
there's
so much home diy and not necessarily
like
the cute home diy like the behind the
scenes
crawling around in the attic digging
around in the walls diy so much of that
was documented on
the blog and i think another thing that
i i
feel so thankful about for this house is
we wouldn't
literally be here doing this podcast
having this youtube channel
really i don't think that we would if it
wasn't for this house yeah because i
mean
we kind of started diy with our wedding
but we got a lot more comfortable with
doing diys
you originated evan and caitlin when we
bought
this house the very first blog
post was about the house the house yeah
and all of all of
you know documenting the buying and
fixing up of this house so
literally we would not like the thing
i'm most thankful
of is we wouldn't be in this wonderful
position we're in right now
if it wasn't for us deciding to buy the
house that's true
you know that's true and and and there's
there's so much that went into us i mean
we we we bought a house that was
probably like
about half of what we were pre-approved
for which was another good financial
decision but also
it kind of put us in a place where we
had to fix up the house and because we
were fixing up the house
we got comfortable with fixing up houses
and then honestly like
when we were watching hdtv and watching
like
people on hdtv we're kind of like we're
kind of like that
yeah very small degree we've done stuff
like that to our house so we could make
videos doing stuff yeah and we'll just
do it on youtube
yeah i mean that wasn't really the
origin story but that was like
one part of the origin story it was
something we kind of considered
yeah a little bit it was one of one of
the things that went into our heads
that and and for some reason we just
didn't think about all of the difficult
logistics
of of it and we just said oh we can do
that
i think we just started yeah the youtube
channel yeah the youtube channel
yeah um but no i think i think
this house gave us like a
kind of low risk it was like a low-risk
experimentation house for us
yeah in a lot of ways yeah i mean well
we we moved in
and then we just like one of the very
first things we did is like went into
the attic and we started messing around
with
plumbing well yeah because we had leaks
when the inspector inspected this house
there was like two active leaks
actively leaking there were two active
leaks
there was like um you know some
electrical issues the whole roof needed
i'm not sure if you've ever shared that
like we couldn't buy this house
oh yeah well i'm about to get to that
but yeah so we had foundation issues we
had two active leaks
we had we needed an entirely new roof we
had big electrical issues
and there was a bidding war on the house
yeah and so we were like
we'll take it like we'll offer even more
pick us um
but then we got an inspector to inspect
all those things and then like
one thing is you can if you get like
quotes for how much things are gonna be
are gonna cost to fix you can like back
that
out yeah of the price so we ended up
being back under asking price but
um but yeah we're like this is a good
idea
but yes one of the crazy things is
we because the roof needed to be fully
replaced and that was such a big deal
we couldn't get in like home insurance
to cover us
until we replaced the roof and you can't
get a loan from the bank
until you have home insurance and
the seller wanted an extra short seven
day option period normally it's like
10 days and the option period is when
like you can pull out
of your you know you can make an offer
but then pull out any time within the
10-day option period
but we only had seven days and so we had
to like
get the roof replaced wait did we get
the roof replaced or do we just get a
quote we got a quote
we just got a question it was it was so
much hustle quotes
inspector like so many different people
out to give us quotes
yeah so that we could get insurance so
that we could get a loan so we could buy
the house well i think that
to a certain degree another thing that
we we learned from this house is
kind of the confidence to just tackle
house projects
i mean that's kind of a strange thing
but for me when i'm learning a new
computer program
or like a piece of software or anything
i just push all the buttons and i just
experiment and i just like
you know figure things out to a certain
degree yeah and
you know with caution we did that to us
a certain degree here i mean
there are certain things that you don't
really want to mess with too much
electrical
and kind of plumbing i mean though we
did we did mess with plumbing and it bit
us in the butt a little bit
but electrical's the main electrical
electrical is the main thing
and we even like pushed ourselves a
little bit and said oh we
let's try that and then we learned no
thailand leveling floors oh yeah you're
jumping from electrical to thailand oh
yeah yeah yeah
yeah there's just like other things
about the house and about
the home owning process that we learned
that like yeah well i'll use the tiling
story we might have told this before but
we were like
hey we so we we hired out
um uh replacing the old tile and carpet
in our house with like laminate wood
flooring
um but we
um in our laundry room they pulled out
the old tile but we didn't want the
laminate wood flooring in there we want
a new tile we just didn't know what we
wanted yet so
when they were done with the floors in
the house we just had like
concrete subfloor in our laundry room
and um the rest of the floors they had
leveled
for the laminate flooring but the
laundry room just that little nook they
hadn't leveled it
um and so we were like well we'll just
that's just such a small room we'll tile
it ourselves
and i think tiling we i think we might
have been okay but leveling
the sub floor was so hard we tried to
get like the right
um like leveling the thin set level and
compound
set but it was just like we either
weren't using enough or
it wasn't liquidy enough it was not
self-leveling oh my gosh
another thing is this house had
foundation issues before we bought it
yeah so like i'm not even sure like how
level the whole house was
it's not it's definitely not that's not
like none of our neighbors
this houses we shouldn't bash it too
much
maybe someone will end up buying and
love
the foundation issues have been fixed
yes don't worry
they have been fixed there's a lifetime
warranty it's great it's
fine nothing is noticeably crooked
except for the walls and the lines
have somewhat crooked walls yeah it's
it's a
great house i think i think
two of the main topics we want to talk
about one lessons learned from the house
but i think i'm already gonna jump i'm
gonna pop open the next topic also and
mix them back and forth let's do it
what would we have done differently with
this house if we had known would live
here for eight years
oh my gosh but i think that another to
keep in mind
is you know when we first bought the
house we we didn't
we didn't know how much money we should
put into it and we did put in a decent
amount of money into the floors
into the roof and everything and like
now some of that we had like backed out
of the price
yeah but still it's like we were still
like we didn't just have like
a lot of you know uh liquid assets
to move around so you know if i
if i you know was being silly and
idealistic and ignoring all costs
we would have you know retextured the
walls and we would have repainted
everything with not chalk paint
you know
potential buyers of our house don't
listen to this part no
no no that's fine it's fine our house is
painted with the extra flat paint
so flat that it's hard to match maybe
some people want that
maybe they do it just makes it hard to
match yeah um
but uh yeah we probably would have
retextured the walls just because we
prefer like a smoother wall texture
we might have like redone some things
and like the master bathroom
just because i think we could have
utilized the space more efficiently for
us um the previous owner
i think lived here with her two
daughters and
had it redone in like a way that worked
for her
but it wasn't necessarily that the best
for us um
guys there's no door between the master
bedroom and the bathroom
there's there's no door there's no door
we didn't realize until after we bought
the house we we really didn't realize
that
no we didn't realize so literally we we
bought the house and then we were like
there's no sliding door there's no
pocket door we have one bathroom with a
door in this house
unless we shut the whole master yeah but
then juba gets in because she knows how
to
oh yeah and that door doesn't close you
can't and you can't reach it
if you're back in the back doesn't latch
no it doesn't so jube gets in
and she opens the door she walks in a
few feet and then leaves and just leaves
the door
open so this door was closed that's
wrong
open open please eye open yes
um i think one interesting thing um was
when we
got the floors done and i'm so glad that
we got those done like early on because
it's really
um you know that it's just a more
disruptive thing
but we only we did all the
um living and dining kitchen and the
hallway but we didn't do the bedrooms
initially yeah
and then like a few years later we were
like man
the carpet in the bedrooms which is
still the previous owner's carpet
we're like it's looking a little rough
jube has barfed on this several times
like like we've been wanting to replace
it
let's just do it but it was kind of a
hassle because the flooring had been
discontinued
and so our flooring company had they had
some but they had to like
really struggle to source it from other
places and we almost didn't get to do it
so like
luckily that worked but if it hadn't
worked that would have been a thing
that i would have wished we'd just done
all at once you know
yeah but those those those things are so
hard
they're much easier to see in in
hindsight yeah but it's so hard to like
know in the moment how long you're going
to be there what's weird is like
when when we moved to this house how
long did you think in your head that we
were going to be here
i thought we were going to be here like
four or five years
me too i thought that we were gonna move
for one of our jobs probably my job
yeah i think i just kind of assumed we
would move because of work because we
both moved a lot growing up
because of our parents work yeah our
parents moved a lot both
sets of our parents moved a lot yeah and
it was you know every fewish
years yeah and so it was just like oh
we'll probably be in this house for a
few years and then we'll move for work
that's just what people do you know um
but we've lived here longer than either
of us have lived in any other
individual place yeah which is weird
it's weird
it's weird i think another thing that i
wish i had of done
like over those eight years we have been
here
is i wish that every now and then like
once a year
like on on on the first day of the year
we should like walk the house as if we
are like new home buyers you know
and like think what do we want to change
and how can we do that
and you know like you know we have the
excuse as you know people who have a
youtube channel where we diy stuff
you know we have redone some things like
the shelves that i'm pointing at right
over there
great wow great but like you know we we
should have like
done that multiple times and like as
we're thinking about selling this house
we've started doing like little things
that we've meant to do for a while like
we took down this ugly shelf that i made
out of
a cabinet side yeah
randomly one day i'm like the size of my
key account i'm just gonna like
put up a shelf using the side of an ikea
cabinet that's
we don't need the rest of the i'll just
take this one panel
and i'll make a shelf and i'll put it
above the door frame where caitlyn can
never reach it and i'll put my
lightsaber up there
and that that's been there for years
took it down so
much better with it yeah we just took it
down last night and we were like huh
we should have done that a really long
time ago what do you think about my
impromptu coat rack
you know the coat rack is less offensive
to me
because it's painted white because it's
painted white to match the walls
and it doesn't take up that much visual
space and we use it
we do use it yeah even though i don't
think we should
like i don't know why we need where the
coat rack needs to be
in the office where we have a coat rack
by the end no but that's so far away i
get cold then i get hot then i get cold
then i get hot
no no no i need to hang it like a proper
boy
really that's your concern
[Laughter]
they should
[Laughter]
laundry
um anyways no man you just do monetize
the whole podcast
gold channel it's okay i think it's okay
um
i just like saw you walking into that i
didn't know how to like stop you soon
enough
oh man there's no there's no hope no
hope
okay so all other things that i you know
less you know wish we had
done earlier wish we had known if we'd
be here for eight years
you know one thing that i wish we would
have done
this is kind of tying it into um the
first question which is like what we've
learned there's some projects
that like i kind of wish we would have
done just to have experienced them on
this like experiment house
oh like like we've never done like a
nice
cabinet painting job you know what i
mean and that's one of those things that
like
you can update places so
like in such a big way which is paint
yeah you know but painting cabinets is
kind of tricky like do you sand them do
you d
gloss them do you you know there's like
all these
various methods that everybody swears by
yeah but also i mean the
part of the problem is you can find one
solution for one house that won't work
for another house
that's very true but at least like there
would be some experience and there's
been several occasions where i was like
man i really want to
paint the kitchen cabinets i really want
to paint the bathroom cabinets looking
looking
if we if we have known that we were
going to be here for eight years we
should have painted
and read on the kitchen sometimes i
think so too because it isn't you know
if you've seen it in our videos it's
kind of like an orangey wood
which is one of our favorites i think
it'd be so cool to have like
white on top and like a navy on bottom
or something
but then it's like oh but you can't have
a
black countertop with a navy bot
like navy bottoms so then we gotta like
replace the countertop you know it
becomes like a whole thing
yeah but there are a few things that i
wish i had just kind of like dipped my
toes into and
tried well i think that i think that
there's like a certain
fatiguing like momentum when you move
into the house you're like energized to
do a whole bunch
and then it just like fades over time as
you just get used to the house and
accept it
yeah you're like well that's just how it
is
yeah you start playing the mental game
of like do i hate it enough
to do that work and risk making it worse
you know what i mean yeah and for
certain things we were like
i don't hate it that much
[Music]
so but there was still a lot that we did
and learned like we replaced
nearly every single light fixture in
this house
um you know we did do some simple paint
upgrades like painting a room
creating the fireplace great light
fixtures
oh best like one of the one of the best
bangs for the bucks
you can you can hope for light fixtures
and i think
paint now we were lucky that our house
is painted a neutral color
yeah but paint can make such a big
difference paint and like light fixtures
paint and light fixtures huge
differences and flooring but that's
getting expensive yeah
it's interesting as we look for houses
katelyn definitely has
like a favorite flooring and it is not
these floors no but it's not too too far
off it's it's kind of
it's it's it's not that far off it's a
lot lighter and a lot more uniform
take our current floors lighten them a
couple shades and make it
make it slightly more uniform and make
it matte
not shiny but that's every every every
aspect
every aspect of it there's still like
wood that's true well these are laminate
but it's still the same look you know
it's not like
now my favorite flooring is um spanish
terracotta tile oh
hex marley oh terrazzo oh no
yes
mustard colored shad carpet let's buy a
house with
concrete floors across the entire house
use it all as a workshop
no epoxy the whole thing doesn't galaxy
holo glitter mica
galaxy okay i'm so so here's the thing
there there haven't many jokes about us
like doing resin galaxy floors
here's the thing i do have fun like
doing crazy resin galaxy rainbow
pieces are you gonna spill the tea maybe
a little bit of tea
but like if i'm thinking about like
especially like
larger impact items in a house that's
not really what i want
like i don't really want a kitchen with
galaxy floors it's
it'd be fun to do but like i don't want
that every day
i want like my light honey colored matte
you know a wide plank flooring that's
now my new favorite flooring anytime i
see it in the house
our aesthetic is like white black and
honey floors
yeah i mean like white walls like black
light fixtures
like stuff like that yeah it's pretty
simple
it's pretty simple yeah yeah um but
white black honey floors
i don't know that i'm trying to sum it
up you know it's not not not
harshly cold modern not super you know
twirly and fancy traditional i think
that our style is
kind of more transitional transitional
which is the most generic
because it's just like in between
but we probably air a little bit more on
the modern side of transitional a little
bit more on the modern
yeah um yeah in an ideal world and
that's kind of like what we've turned
this house into and
slightly slightly yeah i think we've
done pretty good
i think that we we've done pretty dang
good we've doing pretty dang good for
the
for the money and time that we've put
into it i
i like this house yeah i like it too
um i think that like you know there are
some things that are just like
unreasonable like
there's no way that when we bought our
first house we would have known that we
would be starting an entire business in
it
and we would need so much more space i
mean
and if we didn't have this business we
wouldn't need
this much yeah we wouldn't need to move
yeah yeah if we didn't have this
business
we could just you know live very uh
economically here yeah yeah yeah we
would still have plenty of space
yeah i mean honestly one of the things
that i've looked at
when we're looking at a new place is
like you know getting enough
space for everything that we need
is expensive when you stuff it into like
a house you know
a bigger house is just more expensive we
even looked at like
renting warehouse space and it's like as
an alternative
as an alternative or like a supplement
or something who knows how to mix them
but we're like okay
if we buy a cheaper house and then rent
a warehouse
that makes it just as expensive per
month as the bigger more expensive
houses
yeah it's and that was kind of like a
like mind moment for me
because i had been struggling because
like a lot of things we're looking at
online
were like a little bit on the higher
side especially coming from this house
that
like is which was very economically very
economical and very smart and and
responsible
but then when we started looking at the
difference of like you know
the lower end of the price range that we
were looking at in the higher end and we
looked at what that difference would be
per year if you
if you take out like the amount that
you're paying into principle because
that's you know
an investment if you take that out then
it was like
it's a bad deal the difference
in those two different price points of
house was the same
as what we would pay renting a warehouse
like year by year which was crazy and
then it would have to drive farther i
don't want to drive you guys
i don't want to drive anywhere well the
thing is like the way that we work
is very fluid with our life
like like there's not set hours that we
work every day and set hours that
we are not working every day most of the
day is work but a lot of it is like
like we'll um you know
i don't know we we just like intermix it
like we'll run an errand
in the middle of the day that is not a
work thing or like we'll do it to do
that is not a work thing that we need to
be at our house for or it'll be like
late at night and we're like
oh crap we really need to like do that
resin pour tonight if we want to get a
curing
but even you know we wouldn't want to
have to drive to a workshop even if it's
a very standard type
day like like when we're when we're
filming our videos
we'll usually film the intro and then
bring it in and caitlyn will edit it to
make sure
we got it before we break down the intro
setup and move to
the first stage of whatever the video is
and stuff like that and yeah and i guess
so at any workshop we would have to have
an
office we'd have to have an office and
then that really balloons the scope of
the world you know
the space we need to rent and then we'd
have to have like we'd have to have an
office set up there and office set up
here
because like right now it's 9 00 p.m
right now like we would theoretically be
home from the workshop
we're like oh let's just record the
podcast would we would we have a podcast
set up
here like you know at our home and
everything is complicated because then
there's these few duplicates of
everything
and then where's the files and can you
access the files and
do you eat at work most likely lunch at
least but then like
you need a whole kitchen yeah do you
need a whole kitchen and then
where do you store your leftovers and
then how expensive is this workshop
getting
also the leftovers at home or
at work work also super important thing
supervisor supervisor needs to be with
us to make sure we're on task
at all hours of the day she gets very
sad when we're she gets
really sad if we're away yeah yeah she
needs to kind of be
at least somewhat near she's around the
corner right now
right we're sleeping right there yeah
listening to us she likes hearing our
voices
and if we are in another room she
usually kind of follows
us just so that she can like hear our
voices
yeah and that'd be so sad if we were
working away from her i know and if
we're gone from the house even
like just for a walk when we come back
she's at the door waiting meowing like
hey where'd you guys go yeah i missed
you i know it's a very very lucky
position to be able to do something like
this
but like i don't know it's just we've
also been spoiled for the past
we've been completely spoiled and and
it's just it's just crazy to think about
but yeah
thinking also about like when we bought
this house it's interesting because this
house was a lot more than what we needed
it was more than what we needed i mean
two people don't
need a full house most the time
most of the time they don't yeah yeah so
it was more space than we needed and we
had
like we had a whole room that was just a
guest room and nothing else
and a whole room that was like a junk
room wedding room
organizing room yeah it went from like
the wedding room to the junk room to
like you put a desk in here for a little
bit
yeah yeah this is where i put my first
3d printer when i was just like yes i
was like i'm gonna get this 3d printed
and i'm going to turn it into something
i'm going to do something with it
and that kind of helps start us down
this path yeah that also did
but yeah like i guess we're so lucky
that we did have some space to grow into
even though we've now grown out of it it
didn't buy us some time that way we
weren't trying to start the business
and look for a new house without really
knowing what we needed
yeah imagine if we had like hadn't had
enough room in this house to do the
business and we started looking at the
same time we wouldn't have known what we
needed
yeah and when we're looking at you know
our next house we're also doing that for
the next house like we want
you know maybe double the workshop space
which means
probably just a bigger garage and we
want a lot more
house space too you know but we're also
looking at like
places with full workshops yeah also but
it's also kind of hard because it's like
also you have to give something you have
to give you have to give something
up to get something else yeah like
always
and so for the workshop for example if
we're going to get a bigger one does
that mean we need to be farther from
town how much workshop space do we
really need
you know there's all sorts of mental
gymnastics but yeah the amount of
workshops
yeah i'm getting a little we're getting
a little distracted by like talking
about this house versus thinking
our thoughts around the next house but
um this this house has been very
interesting because
i also think that like i'm so glad we
did this because
i can't it would have been very hard for
us to start
this business in the apartment yeah
i mean we wouldn't have had a garage
yeah we had a few tools that we would do
like on our balcony we could have done
some things
not much in our apartment not much
even though our first few videos were
smaller projects well one of one of our
very first videos was like turning our
garage into a workshop
because it was just a garage remember
yeah that was in that first
set of videos that we filmed fixing
drywall we you can't fix your own
drywall
at an apartment oh yeah no it wouldn't
have been a video
like house related stuff we could have
done in the apartment but
also just like storing the tools even if
we just had a few even if i'm just
thinking about the stuff we used in
those
early projects so it would have been
hard and then and then what like
like we it would have been hard our
the main the grey room of our apartment
would have just become a big workshop
it kind of was starting that way we had
a toolbox behind the couch
you know had a few tools in there have
those
ugly man couches yeah they hid the
toolboxes though
yeah because they're so tall i
guys i had i had i had some bachelor
couches
they were like big brown faux pleather
and they were huge they were built for
someone that was
six foot five inches yes they were when
i sat down
the head rest was right here yeah and
when i
sat down and i leaned against the
headrest guess what it did to my head
and pushed it forward because my head
was below the headrest so this big
cushion would just push my head forward
so then i'd have to like scrunch
downwards
and get below it so that i could lean my
head back and so i feel like this
is like like back in the days
back in the six months when we could
like binge watch tv would like
watch watch shows on that couch and get
the one up the worst posture
yeah if you're watching the podcast now
instead of just listening
this is pretty accurate yeah this is
about what we would do
but guys every single seat in that couch
was a recliner
yeah it was so ugly who was that
oh we had a drive-by blessing oh hello
she did a walk by
dubai so now now
let's do a little look at our current
house what are the good and bad things
about this house and i know that like
it's it's weird to like criticize this
great house that we live in that's given
us so much
but like you know i don't know i think
it's an interesting exercise and i think
one thing that we've already mentioned
is
it's too small now i think that's the
main thing honestly is it's just too
small
i also do think that um you know because
it is an older house
there are maintenance things and we have
a hard time keeping up with that
um just because our you know work hours
are
more demanding now than they used to be
i used to have this
amazing spreadsheet it was my home
maintenance spreadsheet
and i had like like how frequently you
you're supposed to do this how
frequently you're supposed to do this
and this and that
and like we just oh hi she's back
we really struggle with that and um
so i think this being an older house
just doesn't work as well with our
current like workload
i think that that i'm realizing too that
i wish
that the the two non-master bedrooms
were a little bit bigger that's true
because we spend
90 percent of our time in this one i
think that's
that's the thing as soon as i started
thinking about moving to a new house
that's the thing that one of the biggest
things that started bothering me is how
tiny
this room is is it 12 by 12 yeah
something
12 by 12 11 by 11. i think that that
honestly probably is a fine bedroom size
but when you have
two people working in it all the time
two big desks and you can't have
this window right here is like a single
like four by two
window that is always closed because we
don't want during the daylight
to disrupt our street stream so we we
are in a 12 by 12 closed
box with two mega desks no no
majority of our life and just a like
there's so much technology like these
desks aren't normal desks
they are like spiders there are arms
coming off of yeah
and like poles they're creatures
creatures
tons of lights that go up to the ceiling
and then the ceiling also is coming down
on us because
we have sound dampening stuff yeah you
know there's like stuff hooked up in the
corners
cameras the green screen and the big
frame we built around that so it's
it's there's like a lot um
in this room and not very much room for
us to move around in no natural light
and
i think yeah like you said i think that
was one of the things even more than the
workshop that we're like
i really want a little bit more office
space in the room where we spend so much
time
yeah in the past four years we've spent
more awake time
in here than doing anything else
at all at all ever yeah it's it's sleep
is number one
being in this room is number two being
in the workshop is number three
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah so i think that's the
biggest thing about this house that
really
gets to me to a certain degree yeah on a
somewhat related note um
the i do wish that this house
had more bigger closet
storage that's the thing that like i
would have loved to do more built-in
storage
if we knew we were going to be here for
even longer um
well it's tough though because we
already put the built-in storage because
either of the bedrooms
is already pretty full and we do like
you know if you do a building
there's a lot of room actually in our
living room for built-in storage
oh like that whole wall where we have
yeah
like all the art media center and stuff
you can use that more efficiently and
do some built-in clothes storage and
still keep some room for art
so i think that's one option i also it's
been really cool to like do like a
ikea hack built-in like you know where
you get you you cut the trim you slide
the cabinets all the way against the
wall
and then you you know build it in
like our murphy beds although like we
the
shelves that we built or that we bought
to do the murphy bed built-ins ended up
not being the
like size that we thought and so there's
some wasted space there
but also i could have seen us getting
like closet systems
you know like container store closet
systems they're so good yeah to like
maximize closet storage
or like um uh you know the room where
where we have the treadmills
yep desks i think we could have done
some built-in storage in there
yeah but if that if someone uses that
for a breakfast nook in the future then
we would have had to tear those out no
no no
um because you can do like a window seat
with a built-in window seat with storage
underneath yeah and then you can either
have the table
if someone turns into breakfast nook
instead of a treadmill room
you can you can like switch the table up
to that and that can be your seating
yeah
yeah that would have been cool that was
that was the thing that i wanted to do
for a bit
yeah we just didn't um but i think like
that would be cool
in terms of like good things about this
house i like the vibe
of the main room i love the vibe of the
main room like
i love just being in there me too and
part of that is the stuff we did to it
part of it is just
like you know tall scenes yeah big tall
ceiling and it has the most natural
light
yeah and it's just like those are the
two probably big things
yeah i don't know it's got vibes it's
got vibes yeah it's got some good vibes
um you know and like
all in all aside from the two bedrooms
being a little small
like i feel like everything was a good
size and there's not much wasted space
like
our breakfast nook slash treadmill room
is a little weird
yeah but you know some rooms or some
houses have like
a formal i guess our house technically
has a formal dining but we only have one
eating area
but it's like the the formal dining and
the formal living and the formal library
and the
formal this and there's or just like a
random
game room or you know at the top of the
stairs there have been
a like a decent number of houses that
we've looked at
that like have had a room in between in
between two other rooms two of the rooms
well i think it's
i think it's like if you have kids and
you want them to have like a shared
playroom
or something i think maybe that's it but
you have to go through one room to then
get to two other rooms
yeah i think that's what they're for
it's interesting
there's so many of them though where
like you you go from the living room to
this other room and then there's
bedrooms off of the room instead of a
hallway
yeah is that is that is that just weird
because we're weird or is that normal i
don't know i mean we've seen a couple
houses
yeah um but i think it did make me like
some of the
inefficient use of spaces of houses that
we've seen made me appreciate
that our house is efficient it is
efficient
you know it is it is but maybe with the
like breakfast nook room that we're
using as a treadmill room is ooh
you know what i wish was better about
our house
when it was being constructed i wish
that like
the people installing electrical and um
the ducting and stuff like that had like
been a little bit more like
careful with like like you know
strapping everything up or
pulled you know tying everything down or
you know like
just just taking a little bit more time
to like
install things in a way that that is
more accessible or
more serviceable and stuff like that
that's true
yeah those are all tiny little picky
things
that we're like now looking but like you
know
everything that's not fully ideal about
this house those have been great
learning lessons for when we're looking
at the next house you know and honestly
like we said the biggest things they're
just like it's too small for us now
and it's an older house yeah the house
can't help how old it is no it really
can't
honestly when we bought it i thought we
were gonna have to put way more money
just into fixing random stuff
that would inevitably break and it's
actually like
it's done well by us it's done pretty
dang good yeah yeah
so thank you house thanks house
yeah well i think the that might that
might be a good place to wrap it do you
have any more thoughts about
our current house no but i do have a
thing of the week to share
no one noticed the technical
difficulties i was wondering
i was wondering why you like put down
the vlog i don't know
i'm just being a silly boy you are
you're silly
um okay so my thing of the week we just
consumed tonight with dinner um but it's
so good
it's hot honey um the specific brand is
mike's hot honey it was a present from
my parents
um over christmas because i like food
related gifts
um and uh we had it on cornbread we had
chili and cornbread and we did the hot
honey
and some butter on the cornbread it is
so freaking good
like i don't know it's it's a it's like
not something i would have thought to
buy for myself like a spicy honey but
it's
so good i think it could also be good on
like
um toaster or i was gonna say i'm like
like fried chicken sandwiches oh yeah
yeah you know what i mean like i think
it's good to have honey
and hot honey oh you need both i don't
want to put hot honey in my tea
that's it's an additional thing though
it's good i think super tasty
kind of savory things where you want a
little spice and a little sweet
i feel like there's like i'm still kind
of new to the hot honey
i feel like there's a lot of things that
would be really good on i think that
honey in general lasts a pretty long
time
it lasts a long time yeah and there's
you know especially certain honeys don't
crystallize but like
you know you get the honey and you you
use it here and there's a nice like
little bam bam we mostly use it on
cornbread when we have chili and
cornbread nice delicious
yeah my thing of the week is actually a
youtube channel
um tyler bell they have been a patreon
of us since february of 2018.
and you know we met tyler yeah it's been
but it's
been really cool to see um tyler stick
with you know his channel he started it
two years ago and he has made you know
he has like continued to make videos
and it's really even interesting to see
his style evolve
and now he's doing some really awesome
things like his most recent one is
he welded up steel cubes and
thicker and thicker walls um to see if
he can stop
ice from expanding when it's submerged
in liquid nitrogen
and i'm not going to spoil anything but
it's cool it's very myth
and he he's admitted that he's taken a
lot of inspiration
from mythbusters he even like you know
three months ago built a blast shield
similar to that the one they use in
mythbusters so he's like kind of going
after a little bit of that
a little bit of the maker uh you know
side of things but it's
it's cool to see to see a channel like
his grow and uh tyler bell check out his
channel yeah it'll be linked in the
description along with my hot honey
but i think um before we do the outro i
wanted to shout out
all of the amazing reviews that have
been coming in you guys have been really
getting into the prank
the prank is a prank in which we we
trick
people who don't know us to listen to
the podcast yes and be confused but i
just want to
read some choice choice reviews yes
um from flash the small sloth
this podcast is life-changing honestly
my cat loves listening to this while
he's climbing on the ceiling
it is very pog from cat
another one do you wanna do you wanna do
um i wanna do that top one this one
right there okay
another one um oh it doesn't say who
it's from
it's just uh and there's just numbers
it's just numbers
i was trying to decide which type of
milled cornflour to use for my cousin's
cornflower sponge cake recipe
and this podcast answered all of my
questions would one hundred percent
recommend
thank you so glad we could answer those
questions for you stars
thank you yeah and you know i i hope we
answered all of your questions today
no matter what they were yeah whatever
they were at if you feel
so compelled to leave us a review maybe
uh
we'll end up reading it in a future
podcast because like i don't
yeah you guys are so funny we always
read them and chuckle yeah all right
um thank you so much for listening um
i need to play the outro music
there you go nope there it is just don't
push that
down anymore just leave it up
alright guys hope you're having a great
day thanks so much for tuning in
and we will look forward to seeing you
in the next thing
bye